a little bit so connect to your [ __ ]
you're on his shoulders blended what
[Music]
those guys are in the middle shooting a
video right now and we just got word
that the corridor digital and seven eco
channels have been hacked and somebody
on Twitter actually tagged me and I
thought I thought quick I checked it out
and I came to you guys right away so
while everybody else was busy shooting
the next corridor digital video me and
Carmichael are going to have to sit down
and figure out how to fix this problem
so I'm going to disable all third-party
apps also need to change the host email
of the account they have to wipe all the
permissions to the accounts the channel
here so you can see what the hack looks
like the names are changing to the
videos still growing so Sam and Nico and
corridors been hacked let's get somebody
is changing all the names that
we down the timeline i right in the
middle of filming like an intense
character moment and Spencer comes
walking in say Nico got high just like
good we're doing all these planning and
all the descriptions into you know they
can see the SAMS core digital email or
the youth the third-party app so we're
going to be looking into both of those
on installing changing passwords or this
is this is a legitimately bad situation
so pissed right now like get me mad do
you know that firm Studio semi one is
attack our owners data hasn't leaked so
check out the channel partners on screen
what's another chance the rock
come on out
oh yeah growin Atlas in here as well you
mrs. across the board
big me okay yeah Everett everyone with
studio71 who's in hackers no one touch
any injection
yeah we consistently because they're
claiming remove access to spun wings
name
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] threw your
thumb you want Nana
well at least if it's that big we can
probably count on YouTube to Roberta and
then fix it all ourselves
yeah okay the rocks channels totally
fine they're doing the only BN CN to be
doing this live stream during new front
almost that's like opened up some weird
gate or whatever but I'm trying to
revoke the problem is they claim so the
[ __ ] way that it's set up is when I
became tell me not to yeah yeah so
hashed a carmine you guys curious head
who's the [ __ ] [ __ ] so we messed
up that was gonna get fired
what's the [ __ ] something what's wrong I
get it
do we even have a width of all the time
over all of our chips no this is this
were studious anyone can see when you
tune bit help us I mean I said
everything like a wrap job field
originally to be burger yeah you're
right like there should be some sort of
NASA like on the hour that it will just
get rolled back to I can use both the
passwords
I've removed three or seventy one from
our ad works hey hey what's up I'm here
guess I could as we were gonna I could
just know my guys guys you know what we
should do well just go out sides on both
sides
yeah tickets in there for any of that
our computers are all secured it was a
third party it was already in that shot
is over yes dude so how likely you can
almost see the pointer
I've been I've been playing entire day
outside it's and lovely get a shot where
I had to drop a bottle off the roof of
the building and it was like there's no
way you're going to hit the mark it's
like a 100-foot drop
there's wind it's going to be completely
impossible there's no way into it and my
person is going to do it the plastic
bottles of the water steps it out
whipped it harder plastic bottle all
right one more glass ball just a dull
check it with this given plastic bottle
so it comes to the time get the real
shot I have a real breakaway bottle half
cup of water
all cameras are lined up I [ __ ] ate
it right in the bullseye great I got
high fives from everybody you got a
point I really like the new branding
we've gone with on the channel yeah you
know I think if we named every single
video at the same title probably moved
up to another ISM suitcase you see now
we should have same title with all of
Roman Atwood slogs all that mealtime I
mean this is probably gonna really work
out runs better for us rugged job is
okay if vGHS gets deleted on YouTube it
will not exist
oh that's right yeah yeah if it gets
deleted
oh I'll exist on that place yeah
Freddie's literally downloading it right
yeah it's like a loading bar Oh
ain't anybody asked you to sign for
third-party crackers and nope I feel
like throwing up really yeah what if
they delete all of our originals
Goodwill Hunting when he sits allant
those those military engineering people
and he's like yes and they're like we
want you to come work for the CIA in
hack code and he's like he goes on that
whole spiel about how whatever those are
the type of people that better be hired
by Google for moments like this
I think you just revert they just revert
you to blurt hear you to brief you watch
hashtag YouTube rewind guys [ __ ]